Magic mushrooms: we know what they do - but
do we know how they work?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and you know
what fascinates me the most about science?
The fact that we're still learning new information
on things that have been around for thousands
of years.
Take psychedelic mushrooms, or Psilocybin
mushrooms.
These have been around since the prehistoric
times.
There's even a theory, called the Stoned Ape
Theory, which proposes that humans evolved
from early primates through the use of psychedelic
mushrooms.
They've been used in religious ceremonies
all over the world for centuries, and it's
suggested that the use of mushrooms and other
psychedelic drugs, are what formed the basis
of modern religion.
Today, people use them mostly recreationally
- and while the effects of mushrooms are pretty
well-known, what's NOT well-known - is how
they actually work.
Until now.
A new study, published in Human Brain Mapping,
finds that psilocybin - the active chemical
in psychedelic mushrooms - is closely tied
to the parts of our brains that help us dream.
Now logically, this makes sense.
Psychedelic drugs are notorious for transporting
users into a heightened state of consciousness
- which explains why they're often used in
a spiritual context.
The part of our brains that get activated
during dream sleep - are tied to the brain's
ancient emotion system.
And when someone takes psychedelic drugs,
that area of the brain becomes uninhibited
- so their emotions seem to get "louder."
What's interesting, is that the ego system
- the part of brain that gives us our sense
of self - actually gets quieter and more disjointed,
under the effects of psychedelics.
So it's believed that the "quieting" of that
ego system - is what allows our emotional
system to become louder.
According to the author of the study, Dr.
Robin Carhart-Harris, psychedelics cause "ego
dissolution" - meaning they temporarily diminish
one's sense of having a firm and enduring
personality.
At the same time, they widen the breadth of
associations made throughout the brain - which
is what enhances our creativity, and causes
that state of "expanded" consciousness.
That also explains why they're sometimes used
in psychotherapy.
Because they help patients facilitate an emotional
release.
Speaking of emotional releases, I'm sure many
of you heard the news this week - about Hobby
Lobby and the Supreme Court Ruling allowing
them to deny contraception coverage for their
employees.
At the risk of alienating half of our audience,
I will keep my opinions to myself on this
one - BUT I wanna remind everyone that we
have a new show called Test Tube - hosted
by Trace and myself - that's a lot like Dnews,
but focused more on current events.
We've got a new episode up, where Trace talks
all about the Hobby Lobby ruling - and what
it means for America.
So if you're looking to learn more about that
situation, we'd love it if you checked out
the show.
You can find that episode - and many more
- over at youtube.com/TestTubeNetwork.
In the meantime, if you've got any questions,
comments, anything you wanna say about this
episode - or psychedelic drugs in general
- leave em in the comments below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching!